now what about this what's a wild thing
somebody wants to have in there when
they die somebody throw in a little can
of ruffles or somebody put a little
couple starbursts in there or something
okay you know it's it's not uncommon a
big thing a lot of people take
cigarettes with them
you know because you take somebody who's
smoking a boy
you know they'll put those they'll put
that you know cigarettes in that shirt
pocket you're gonna want that smoke dude
if you did
if i'm dead bro light me up a damn 100
baby you know what i'm saying i'm
burning a [ __ ] winston dog
if i'm dead man i ain't milling around
you know i've had you know you know a
lot of people put pictures of themselves
you know and what about a joint somebody
sneak a joint in there sometimes um i'm
not gonna say that that's never happened
because you know when we're when we're
standing back up there and the family
goes up for their final viewing there's
no telling
what they can stick in there you know
i've had i've had some very interesting
stuff you know i had somebody
request to be buried with their shotgun
amen you know so they took their shotgun
with them
you know what about can they now if
somebody requested me bear with an eight
ball
you know and i'm not talking bowling i'm
talking about cocaine baby
can you make can you make do you have to
do that
well the thing about it is since that
would be an illegal drug
you know we wouldn't be required to do
that but you know if somebody
if somebody were to bring that in and
you know stick it up under the foot of
the casket
you know i'm not i don't keep a drug
sniffing dog at the funeral home
so it might just go on through you know
they might just go with them that might
go with them yeah so
yeah that's one thing there's no tsa
when you're flying up to heaven
that's right that's right you're not
gonna be you're not gonna be searched
you know so now uh what's the wildest
thing somebody's put in there somebody
ever put something that's a little too
big in there
you know somebody try to put a little
chainsaw or a leaf blower or something
if somebody died doing a uh
you know during a dangerous you know
leaf blowing or something you know
no i don't think they've had any power
tools or anything like that
you know sometimes you have like
stuffed animals or whatever you know
even for like an older person they'll
bring like stuff to animals they'll
bring
blankets sometimes and you know we've
had um
you know like fishing rods you know
stuff like that
that have gone with them but you know as
far as you know i've never put
i don't think any power tools in there
but
i'd go with a damn sander or something
you know so what are you going to use
that sander for
who knows but i'll tell you this if you
show up
and you the only dude with a sander
you're going to be you're going to be
steady working
that's right but we're not supposed to
work in the afterlife but i'm sure
there's a couple opportunities to make
alone you always
want to decide i want that side hustle
now do you take those items out or those
those items go on
the family gets it's the family's choice
if the family
wants something in there for visitation
and then they want that back we'll take
it out but if they wanted to go with
them
it goes with them now you close the
casket during the
if it's an open casket you guys close it
during the procession
or funeral deal it depends on when the
family wants that closed you know
if they want it closed at the beginning
of the service some families like for
everybody to file by at the end
one final viewing and then after that
after the family goes up for their final
viewing
then we close the casket so a lot of
times that's up to the family
can somebody get buried with their money
if they want to
if they want to bring it in they can get
buried with it have you ever had
somebody that that was their request and
they put it in there
not all their money you know i've i've
had people you know want to get married
you know
with you know granddaddy always wanted
him kept a
you know a two dollar bill or you know
he always had
change in his pockets you know didn't
want to go anywhere without a little
money
you know i've had that but i've never
had anybody say we're gonna put a
million dollars in this casket
yeah because you know then you
then you get to the age-old question
if you put a million dollars in there
let's say you put a million dollars in
there in cash
and then if somebody would take the cash
and write you a check for it you've
still got a million dollars
so so nobody normally puts cash in there
they just
maybe we'll put a check yeah so i guess
if you want to i guess if you wanted to
go with a million dollars we could write
you a check for a million dollars
because
you wouldn't be able to cash it yeah
yeah i'd rather send the check
yeah just in case later you decide dang
i wish i had that cash
yeah yeah yeah but nobody ever puts
million dollars or anything in there
you know so um have you noticed over
time that people bury
used to bury nice things with people and
now they just kind of bury whatever with
them
you think has it been any been able to
notice anything like that
you know most of the time people if it's
something of real value they keep it and
they pass it down in the family or
whatever
you know you especially jewelry and
stuff like that
and of course now with you know there's
so much stuff that
you know people are using like costume
jewelry and stuff like that
that people are wearing rather than
buying you know
real expensive jewelry that they're
doing that they're doing that
and especially for um especially for
your older people
because as they as they get sometimes
dementia and stuff like that
the family's already taking their good
jewelry away from them
so they don't lose it because you know
they don't want them to keep the good
jewelry
in the nursing home or stuff like that
and
you know because they'll you know
they'll lose it or somebody will steal
it or whatever
now i have had families bring in really
nice jewelry for the visitation in the
funeral
and then they want that back and so have
you ever stolen anything from anybody
no sir no sir that that'd be bad for
business
yeah it'd be bad for business man i
didn't think you had but i just had to
ask good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watches one ah